mesdames messieurs voici Tom villa
désormais en CDD
alors toi faut que tu apprennes mon
petit gars c'est qu'il est passé CDD là
il était stagiaire
alors tiens fais-moi une interview
d'André Dussollier pour te là maintenant
là maintenant à froid comme ça
vas-y ça va
première question est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper oh non
c'est trop direct moi je trouve
franchement non mais c'est comme avec
une fille il faut y aller doucement
fais-lui un compliment vous êtes très
bien conservé pour votre âge
c'est pas un film c'est une pièce
tu fais sa carrière quand même eu des
Césars c'était pas vous dans trois
hommes et un couffinez pas le petit brun
bouclé
alors donc là c'est une pièce vous
l'avez vu la pièce d'ailleurs ou quoi
je la revisite tous les jours
et le prix va de combien à combien le
prix des places pas cher 20 euros c'est
pas le genre de question je sais pas et
vous êtes parti où en vacances
je suis parti sur une île d'accord
je vous laisse les interviews il y a pas
de souci en plus déjà je suis très
content parce que l'année dernière
j'étais stagiaire là je suis passé CDD
donc ça c'est j'adore la TNT pour ça
c'est vrai qu'il y a des promotions
comme ça
on a fait un sondage juste là cet été il
y a quelques jours sur Internet et les
gens voient que je passe en CDD avec 63%
des voix
[Applaudissements]
qui dure jusqu'à 21h parce que
maintenant on a une demi-heure de plus
c'est une bonne nouvelle et après il y a
un documentaire sur moi
et après
il y a le printemps des dix ans de
terriens sur Canal et que personne
n'avait vu en face de la fête de la
musique c'est extraordinaire ça veut
dire que ça fait 6 heures d'antenne
ça va Thierry super coup je suis là je
suis d'attaque pour la nouvelle saison
en tout cas ça fait plaisir il y a des
magnifiques invités ce soir je suis
vraiment très content très très beau
plateau
c'est un plaisir un honneur de vous
recevoir vous faites partie du
patrimoine cinématographique français
des acteurs qu'on a toujours connu vieux
ça c'est
André c'est la classe vous avez une
bibliothèque qui porte votre nom à
Cruzet
voilà Thierry lui il a une salle de
shoot et une boîte échangiste
vous avez cartonné au cinéma avec le
film adopte un veuf plus gros million de
spectateurs
ça a donné l'idée à la droite de créer
adopte un républicain pour 2017 alors
bon pour le moment il cherche toujours
le comédien principal parmi les 9
candidats la primaire le casting touche
bientôt à sa fin on le problème c'est
que tout le monde joue mal c'est
horrible on dirait un épisode de Plus
belle la vie ça c'est le
[Applaudissements]
on a du soulier ou network ce soir pour
être nouvelle pièce qui s'appelle novée
de cento voilà votre personnage est un
bébé né sur un paquebot abandonné dans
une boîte en carton recueilli par
l'équipage c'est beau on dirait une
chanson de Linda de Suza
c'est le portrait d'un pianiste né sur
un bateau et jamais descendu en gros
c'est un peu un croisement entre Michel
Petrucciani et un migrant voilà c'est en
gros alors tout votre spectacle se
déroule sur un paquebot alors sans nous
dévoiler la fin est-ce que à la fin vous
heurter un iceberg sur une chanson de
Céline Dion ou pas
oui il y a l'iceberg même il y a le
bateau il y a tout on voit tout très
bien
Rachida Dati bonsoir
non non Rachida ça me fait très plaisir
de vous revoir parce que je le sais
voilà quand vous étiez venu la fois
dernière on va pas se mentir je vous
avais pas fait marrer voilà ce qu'on
peut revoir la réaction de Rachida sur
une de mes blagues s'il vous plaît
je vous jure c'est pas grave et je vous
en veux pas on va repartir sur des bases
saines non mais vraiment chien voilà en
plus j'ai pris ma carte dedans aux
républicain et non c'est pas des
conneries c'est vrai c'est Patrick
Balkany qui me l'a fait pour 1000 euros
en cash et ah il y a eu un début
il y a eu un début on garde espoir on
lâche rien en plus on a tous les deux
une passion commune l'art de la vanne
vous avez dit Nicolas Sarkozy le
meilleur d'entre nous et j'avoue c'est
là je l'avais pas trouvé
ça y est c'est officiel vous êtes assez
coté alors je suis à le préciser comme
conseiller politique à la primaire de
droite pas comme avocate dans l'affaire
bigmalion
tu vas l'énerver
en tout cas vous faites partie de la
liste de Nicolas Sarkozy les autres
conseillers sont sont David Douillet et
Brice Hortefeux
j'ai rien dit j'ai rien mais vous avez
vu comme quoi des fois on s'emmerde à
chercher des vans et puis là ça tient
tout seul
ça marche
Jérémy Ferrari Jérémy humoriste
spécialité l'humour noir voilà je trouve
ça débile de mettre des couleurs à
l'humour vraiment
non mais ça c'est drôle ou c'est pas
drôle l'humour voilà puis c'est comme il
y a des catégories du mot il y a
l'humour juif aussi c'est la seule
religion qui a son humour
catholique ça serait quoi ça serait pas
un prêtre qui fait croire un enfant qui
a un autre petit Jésus mais qu'il faut
le dire à personne
[Applaudissements]
depuis 9 mois Jérémy vous êtes l'homme
qui a emmerdé Manuel Valls
depuis quelques jours vous avez été
rejoint par Macron et
entre temps pas de contrôle fiscal pas
de drogue retrouver dans son coffre de
voiture et vous êtes toujours en vie ça
peut ça peut bien
et toi forcément quand tu attaque Manuel
Valls il peut y avoir des conséquences
alors que là l'avantage ce soir c'est
que si j'ai une Rémy je sais pas
s'engueule avec André Dussollier au pire
tu vois tu vas te vexer avec Sabine
Azéma
avec un manager de chez Dior donc voilà
en tout cas bravo vous avez très bonne
critique dans la presse non c'est vrai
ça cartonne il paraît que danse magazine
vous avez quatre têtes décapité sur 5
vraiment la semaine prochaine
mesdames messieurs je suis ici pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser oui vous aussi
Rachida mais on va terminer par vous ça
sera plus rigolo
André Dussollier vous avez dit le regret
ne m'intéresse pas même 4 ans après
avoir voté François Hollande
vous avez été repéré par Laurent Ruquier
ça vous fait quoi d'avoir un point
commun avec Stevie Boulay
moi j'adore Stevie boule je trouve je
trouve vraiment très très sympa et très
très drôle moi je suis d'accord avec on
va le recevoir cette année j'espère que
il viendra il a fait un roman
monarchiste en plus il le sait ou pas
pour terminer Rachida Dati Rachida vous
préférez toutes votre vie vous fait
réveiller par Elise Lucet dans votre lit
ou bien
toute votre vie partagez le même
dressing que NKM
dans les deux cas j'ai eu le dessus non
bonne réponse
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu